foreign
[Music]
Dark Soul is selected for Redemption by
the ghosts of Christmas past present and
yet to come the tradition that continues
to this very nice
Like A Christmas Carol yes yes if you
would just let me get this outfit so out
of all the people on the planet
murderers people who do gender reveal
parties I'm the guy you're gonna hunt
you know what forget it
foreign
ER Dickens come on I can take this guy
I'm your Ghost of Christmas present
I'm not watching your dramatic
re-encrapment hey I'm haunting you you
can't just run away from me when I'm
haunting you hello
I believe he can be a positive force for
mankind and he's got his hands all over
everything yeah I wish Mom are you
texting HR no
people don't shame we got a runner
that's just fun to watch
I'm here to change into being a more
positive force for Humanity
[Laughter]
yeah you photoshop yourself into these
pictures of my executive VP thanks so oh
you want that what I want is for you to
shut up and let me do my job is there a
Ghost of Christmas grumpy because you
could do that job
[Music]
because where real change begins
Oh that's oh he's dead yeah he's
definitely no no he's fine he's good
well I'm not a burial anyway
[Music]
[Music]